[Music]
welcome to our first episode of PT at
the movies where we get you ready for
what's hitting theaters this weekend I'm
ash Carlton I am John Boone and as you
can see today we are talking about the
most wonderful woman in the superhero
galaxy mantis we're talking about
guardians of the galaxy vol tail vol 2
we've got our we've got our rocket
rocket most matching Rockets are not a
group baby group time to baby gross yeah
baby group and then you've got your
jacket on I've got a little star-lord
for you today
and don't think I'm wearing it as well
as Chris Pratt but I'm trying let me
just say I loved gardius the galaxies
going once so much as such a special
place my heart because as a media person
it was the first movie that I worked on
from when it was announced when it
actually premiered of course walking out
of a theater I already can wait for
volume 2 and it's finally here and I
loved volume 1 it's certainly in my top
1 maybe 1/2 Marvel movie number 1 but
almost exactly a year ago to the state I
was on the set of volume 2 and that was
really cool you have a lot of insights
I've got some insight I've got as much
insight as Marvel will let you have
let's run down everything that we need
to know where we pick up the plot of the
actual movie I'm going to read you the
one-liner is that the guardians must
fight to keep their newfound family
together as they unravel the mystery of
Peter feels true parentage off of layers
here that's the one plot line you like
can't talk about it's all spoilers if
you start taking into that let's say I'm
just a casual fan and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is such an
overwhelming world there's so many
movies on the hood
yeah and I know at this point they kind
of say we're not really trying to bring
in the casual fan anymore but let's say
I am what do I actually need to know
before going absolutely the nice thing
about this one is it has been a few
years since Volume one it has been a few
years since our band of intergalactic
misfits guarded that galaxy for the
first time but only a few months have
passed in the Guardians verse so you
don't need to know about Voltron you
don't need to know about ant-man you
don't need to know anything else this is
probably the most self contained Marvel
movie that's happened in a while you
don't even need to know about Thanos and
he was a big person
they talk about him but you don't see
them right they talk about the Infinity
stones those all-encompassing Infinity
stones you don't see them I would almost
say for this one you really just need to
see the first one and then if you have
more knowledge than that then you just
kind of get some fun surprises along the
way yeah so we can get into what we
first and we thought the biggest
differences between the first and second
movie are later but we will and we will
and we will but we did talk to James
Gunn about this and in his own words
what he thinks the biggest actors I
think the biggest difference is that in
the first movie it really was the story
of Peter quill and you know surrounded
by these supporting players the second
one is a story about all of the
Guardians they each get their own story
we learn a lot more about Gamora and
Groot and nebula in rocket they each
have their own stories not to mention
you know yondu and Drax and mantas the
new characters so there's a lot of them
and that's very true I don't get into
those specifics of those characters
later because there's a lot to get into
but who is the returning from attorney
cast it's really who you would expect it
to be it's your guardians it's your
star-lord it's your gamora's your Drax
is your Groot it's your kind of group
it's your rocket and then it's yondu who
was a very big part in the first movie
you're not going to forget him it's
nebula another big part from the first
movie you're not going to forget her one
thing from set that I thought was
interesting was James Gunn said Glenn
Close who plays Nova prime in the first
movie was going to be in this one and
she's not yes they cut out all the
little people from the first movie it's
just the main ones that you would
remember anyway but we do have some new
players yes new players sighting
exciting any players can we consider a
little group a new player can you
consider someone who stole the entire
first movie in their one second little
pot dance a new player he is a lot of
Newport totally different yeah it's a
totally different character basically
than who else we have we have mantis
mantis is so cool and so weird and I
think James Gunn loves her I wouldn't be
surprised if he like popped her a little
bit when they started shooting and then
yeah she's so good with Drax her stuff
with Drax is some of the funniest
the movie I even remember back at
comic-con Jame Gumb captain mentioning
her to the fire I was like she's going
to have a bigger part than we think she
does
uh I'm set I just remember this he said
he was like she did something with this
character during the audition process
that was the most amazing thing he'd
seen in either the Guardian movies so
like she her audition was essentially
better than Chris Pratt better than Zoe
Saldana better than Bradley Cooper did
you audition I don't know what I look
like and then of course Kurt Russell
yeah I know can we go now I don't think
we should say that much this is one case
where I actually do think
Marvel's clampdown secrecy on it is
worth it I think the least you can know
going into this movie about ego in
actual Living Planet the better what I
love about his addition to the cast is
that Chris Pratt was such a big fan of
his and they connected so much on set
you learn to sort of like be cool you
know and and I think ultimately the the
best part is is moving past that stuff
which to both him and I is we both
understand is pretty meaningless and so
I think we move right past that almost
immediately and go into the things like
our personal connection that we have
with this is you know similar passions
that we share like we really do seem
like we're from of the same ilk you know
we're both outdoors men we you know like
to fish and hunt and get outside and
there's a lot of similarities there and
things we can relate to we were just two
guys and been on the subway yeah I mean
we can talk about in a spoiler-free kind
of zone of what worked and what didn't
for you I mean has Kurt Russell ever
been a not great addition to the cast
but you know one thing if I if I did
have to nitpick and I don't want to
because I think everything was just
turned up a lot it was all you do it
literally was like volume 1 volume 2 I
did think there was a like maybe a
little too much humor at some point oh
this movie has never met a gag it didn't
like he never met a one-liner it didn't
like their philosophy is more as more
and for the most part I'm like yeah I'll
take it
I don't have a problem with you spending
like eight minutes on a baby group gag
you know the first one I think I was a
little timid it was my first really big
movie that I was direct
and I was like I don't know I don't want
to be too much of a comedy and the
second one I'm like I'm just going to go
all James Gunn go all out let it be as
funny as possible and and also let let
it be as emotional as possible and
really to show all the different sides
of these characters I felt very free on
this one I do love that I thought that
he was just kind of free to do the thing
I think Marvel really trusted him to
just go with it I mean it shows to a
degree like the stuff that it does kind
of redo from the first movie it like
you're seeing it with fresh eyes we're
not getting into too many spoilers but
there's a baby Groot dance sequence at
the beginning that is a breath of fresh
air right and it was the one thing I
will say about volume 2 - it was like
it's gonna live in the shadow of the
first road that was like that was I've
heard people say that's the lightning in
the bottle scenarios are never going to
recreate you have to go into this one
knowing that it's going to be something
different but they did do the callback
so that I think we kind of married and
every buddy that I've heard of talked
about is like it's a great movie it's so
much fun it is it as wonderful and
magnificent and weird and strange was
the first one it certainly tries to be I
think it is I think most of us went into
Volume one complete like of course there
was people that knew the comics quite
good and I went into that movie
completely not knowing what to expect
and walking out out there to speak like
what's the best thing I've ever seen
so now you're going into this one with
an expectation right and whether it
lives up or not I think is gonna be up
to you but I loved it I loved it ended
up speaking of love I love that this
movie for as cool as it is and how savvy
and swaggy it thinks all its characters
are it's like openly schmaltzy it wears
a tart fully on its sleeve and it's like
it's cool left absolutely well what did
you would you think of the contract
there's so many great music cues and
this one like the Fleetwood Mac use of
the chain so since there's a song choice
towards the end of the movie that made
me tear up
well you do have a little bit of insight
because Zoe was telling us that
she was listening to music on set the
day I was on set was the day they were
playing Fleetwood Mac the chain and they
laughed it through the speakers as the
characters are acting and the actors all
said they did love it
and so we loved it but I remember her
walking off set being like it's
Groundhog Day I love this song but it is
always playing as artists music plays
such an important role in you putting
something together
sometimes the song can just take you
somewhere really quickly and then you're
feeling all those sensations that you
were experiencing at that time so I
think that music for James Gunn does
that for him he writes these scenes or
the story with the music always playing
in the plate and in the background and
for him to play it for us it just it
eases up into whatever emotional beat
we're channeling and it's super fun okay
so before we say anything else why don't
we end it here
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 comes out
May 5th and we are going to do a spoiler
video tour or a spoiler warning tomorrow
on e t--'s YouTube page to check that
out subscribe like comment so we can
keep doing videos like this come back
come back after
[Applause]
you